I'm on a water pill, small dosage, which is not helping very much.
Doctors concerned about electrolytes.
I have a recipe for one-fourth of both cream of tartar and heavily in salt with warm water.
I know salt is the best with thyroid issues.
Can you give me any suggestions?
If you want suggestions to increase electrolytes, so electrolytes are minerals.
If you want to increase electrolytes, typically when you're talking about electrolytes,
in your body you're talking a lot about sodium chloride and potassium.
Again, how do you increase those?
It is with salt, so it is using salt.
There's products on the market that are for electrolytes.
What do they have? They basically have salt.
If your purpose is just to increase those levels, then using salt in a form of heavily in salt may be appropriate.
You have to look at your blood test and see what your low one.
So well, no, not low on potassium, no, my low on sodium and chloride.
If sodium and chloride are low, then just taking salt is going to increase them.
If not, then you don't need to do that.
You look at a blood test, but I don't see anything wrong with doing that.
And I don't see that carbonate or thyroid gland.
If you're low on sodium and chloride, you do need more salt.